when i took a bite of this i swear my
life just like flashed before my eyes
hey
[Music]
it's no secret that rapper rich brian
has bars
but i also hear he has some serious
skills in the kitchen
i had to see it for myself so today i'm
learning the rich brian method of
cooking the perfect
rib eye steak and in return i'm showing
him how to make a thick patty
dry aged juicy 400 [ __ ] dollar
steakhouse burger
complete with white truffle and caviar
straight up
baller vibes can he live up to the hype
you be the judge
what up y'all what up y'all welcome to
the burger show
i'm excited to have our guest we've been
on the first week feast family for a
minute now but we've never met
rich bride hey today is something
special
because it's something that you love
it's something that i love
and that's meat meat
rich brian loves meats i love me
around 18 19 i like went to the grocery
store and i saw like a rib eye
and i was like i want to try making that
i want to get it right every time and
that's just like where the obsession
kind of came from yeah
i just recently opened a new butcher
shop in chinatown called amboy quality
meats
i pulled out all the stops all right and
i got the best stakes in my case and i
brought them here today and we're gonna
make some magic [ __ ] yeah
if you trim really good steaks the
leftovers
make the most amazing burgers i bet i
wanna learn
about the rich brian technique okay on
making steaks
there's three beautiful prime rib eyes
there why prime
why rib eye because rib eyes are the
most tender steaks that you can get
in my opinion the first time i tried
like a rib eye i
just felt like i don't know if filet
mignons are just kind of like a little
overhyped
even if you get like a choice ribeye
it's still kind of tender
true and you know there's choice there
is
um select select that's the lower one
right select is probably what you get at
the chain steakhouse right
yeah i'm pretty impressed that you knew
you know whatever
hobby i pick up i like to get super into
it and like the nerdy kind of details of
it
we're gonna nerd out today all right i
had them tempered for you though they're
not cold
okay how are you supposed to do it right
yep you're sure
yes okay show me step one
okay to be honest with you it's been a
while since i made a steak
so if i [ __ ] up the temperature
i'm gonna be really embarrassed but at
least i said that in the beginning put
some salt on it
you're not shy with the salt that's so
key for a good steak
this cut is kind of thick so i want to
make sure it's kind of seasoned all the
way through
sometimes i kind of like do this thing
where i just like put it on the board
and
like that's that's pro movement dude do
a little
yo yes yeah
people just just chill fresh brian knows
what he's
doing wait i've actually never cooked a
steak with like this
string on it do i just leave it on or
yeah you leave it on
okay these are little booby traps i've
set up for you my friend
so okay because this is prime and
because we let it temp
we wrapped it in butcher twine so it
doesn't fall so it doesn't fall apart
got it
just a little bit of garlic powder just
a little bit dude because i love garlic
i'm just gonna crush up some of it and
fresh garlic fresh garlic always has to
be fresh yeah
the rich brian technique so far
perfect okay the sears looking really
nice
he's constantly flipping his stick which
means your new school
the way chefs like me make steaks is we
don't just let it sit there
right we constantly flip it to get an
even texture all around
bam yeah as you can see i'm getting some
sear going
i put the butter in butter is in
butter's in garlic is in
you threw a little fanciness in there
what is that that's rosemary
no big deal and you're basting i kind of
do this like
when i feel like my steak is almost done
you don't want to burn the garlic you
don't want to burn the butter and you
definitely don't want
burnt rosemary i will say though the
steak is curling up a little bit and
that makes me a little bit nervous
i think that's a good tell sign that
it's done yeah yeah what are you
supposed to do are you gonna cut it
right away
no you let it rest bam
usually when you let it rest the residue
heat will cook the steak a little bit
more
yes oh
okay that one's pretty good that one
slice you just cut right now this one
and you got to swag it out like hold it
up and just brag about it
you see this [ __ ] social distance
social this is height man this is just
top to bottom
you know pink is not too bloody you know
first it's not blood it's myoglobin
myoglobin is not blood fat
so all the well done eaters out there
you're not eating blood i don't even
know what i'm [ __ ] doing here
this is the rich brian's show
this is like one of the best steaks i've
ever cooked wow
to be honest i'm pretty blown away by
this you've passed the test so far
now i gotta try this [ __ ] there you go
[Music]
so obviously i'm a spineless dorsey guy
you know what that is is that the cap
it's a rib eye cat so we're like
this is like a french chef cooked it i
do
yo-ho-ho okay oh my god
the sear is perfect the seasoning is
right there it just brings out
all the beefiness you can cut this steak
with a fork
that's how you know your store is lit
it's lit
and it's cooked perfectly everyone in
this room right now
their mouths are watering i feel bad i
don't
you just showed me how to make an
amazing steak
so let's take your power and we'll take
my burger power
yep and we'll do the fusion thing we'll
fuse it
we're gonna fuse it exactly and we're
going to make an amazing
steakhouse burger i've become a meat
dealer
i'm the meat pusher in downtown l.a yeah
so what i have for you right now are my
basic cuts
yeah this is basic okay check this out
bam yo
what the [ __ ] 116 days
dry age american wagyu beef
ribeye tomahawk we're turning this into
a hamburger oh that [ __ ] is going down
there like
butter oh man that looks beautiful
that's some fred flintstone [ __ ] when i
say jordan
elephant cement print this is what we're
talking about
so this is a filet mignon the reason why
this is in the blood
is for texture okay a nice tenderness
and then we have new york strip
this is here because it has amazing fat
cat
then we have the best yep it's made out
of rib eye
but it also has dry age it has that
nuttiness it's got that nice funk oh my
god
we're basically intensifying the beef
flavor yeah
let's get started let's do it i know
it's looking a little unfair
i got this big ass behemoth of a meat
grinder uh-huh
and we got you this chode
a hand crank like any kitchen
i'm gonna have to make you pay your dues
i'll let you have a head start
because jars is gonna take way longer
than mine
is it going in no go the other way
does that just come back out again yeah
they call that tamping
away oh yeah there you go
it's a nice little workout 37 minutes
later
to his credit he's not giving up
here it is boom my turn
that looks so much easier it's coming
out so much faster too
when it's a steakhouse burger you don't
want it thin grab the ground beef
and just make a bowl in a circular
motion like that
wow pack the meat in and then press like
this
and we're gonna salt it just like you
did with your steak
flip it over and then pepper we're gonna
let this sit for a little bit
cool we're gonna cut our bun i mean look
at the sesame seed coverage on that bad
boy
and then i'm gonna grab a little bit of
this butter we'll go right into the pan
you wanna get that butter to cover the
entire bun so that you don't have dry
spots
see how you're touching it right now
it's kind of firm yeah that's gonna give
it's just gonna like
loose that's you know when the bun's
ready to go we're gonna make truffle oil
mayo we're just gonna drizzle it on top
of the mayo we're folding it in
oh can you smell that oh my god since we
have our mayo ready
we have our buns ready let's start
cooking this steak burger
pop a little bit of oil on here and i'm
going to throw this patty on
you hear that that's that's magic sounds
[ __ ] sexy i like to just give it a
little bit of a press
to make sure that the contact gets in
there and gets a nice sear
three or four minutes on that side cool
we'll get a little bit of this truffle
mayo we'll spread it on the bottom
and then on the top i'm going to flip it
over oh
we got that caramelization right there
right we're going to throw a little bit
of butter in here
and then i'm ladling it onto the burger
since this is a fancy steakhouse burger
yes
i actually brought roclet and raclette
is famous for
melting let's grab your torch i see what
this is
this has become something of legend on
the burger show i hope i don't blow
myself up
oh
[Music]
do this circular motion it's like
bubbling already
this is that like fire ass line you say
and you just drop the mic after we're
put on the bottom bun
that already looks like an amazing
burger mm-hmm but that's not good enough
for rich brian
a little bit of white truffle and we're
gonna shave that i love white truffle
it's crazy that's new money nice yeah i
made like a little flower
yeah we more economied the [ __ ] out of
this right exactly and then
again guys rich bryant is on the show
he's a first we feast
family member cat like reflexes
what i have right here is caviar service
so we're gonna top the burger i want you
to put a little bit
on your wrist okay and i want you to
make sure the quality is good
wow that is better than any caviar i've
ever tried cut
load your burger up okay use all of that
okay cool
you can give it a nice little push like
that let's give it a little flex to the
camera
this is the rich brian steakhouse
steak burger just the meat alone was 300
we broke it up there's two let's just
call it 150. we put about 100
worth of caviar on it that little baby
piece of truffle like 125 bucks
are you serious so this would probably
be like a 400 dollar burger
jesus marked up
oh my friend yeah perfect
man let's give it a try all right
wow when i took a bite of this i swear
my life just like flashed before my eyes
hey i want my girlfriend to try this
shirt
v where are you v let's go there she is
you can do i tried this one on this one
i would try this one maybe okay okay v
are you into all this stuff
um i'm really picky when it comes to
burger so
it's really stressful like if it doesn't
taste good then i instantly get sad
so i just don't order burgers that much
oh wow okay
well not really what do you think this
is really good i've never tried
cubbier either yeah we're breaking all
kinds of rules caviar wait i'm going to
take another bite go for it please
this is like the best burger i've ever
tasted in my entire life
that's big i'm flattered and it all goes
back
to making it yourself cooking for people
that you love
cooking for new friends cooking for old
friends at the end of the day that's the
essence
of our rich brian steakhouse
burger download
all of rich brian's music watch them on
youtube
burger show baby burger show baby
what's up burger world thank you for
watching make sure you hit that like
button
smash that subscribe button ring that
notification bell
if not for me for the burgers
i love you